if you flip three fair coins what is the
probability that you'll get at least two
tails the tree diagram below shows all
the possible outcomes of flipping three
coins and the top of the tree this shows
us the two outcomes for the first coin
and then given each of those outcomes it
shows us what's possible for the second
coin so if we got heads on the first
coin we could get a heads or tails on
the second coin got the tails on the
first coin or we could get a heads or
tails on the second coin and then for
each of those outcomes it shows us the
different outcomes for the third coins
so let's just think about what where on
this how do we represent getting at
least two tails or what are the total
outcomes and which of those meet our
constraints of getting at least two
tails
so this this node right over here this
is getting a heads on the third coin a
heads on the second coin we just have to
follow up the tree and a heads on the
first coin so this is getting three
heads so this is definitely not going to
meet our constraint
this this node right over here we have a
head head this is often called a leaf if
we're talking about a tree diagram
a head head and a tail so that's one
tail that doesn't meet our constraint of
at least two tails what about this one
here heads tails heads once again only
one tail so that doesn't meet it
heads tails tails this one does so let
me color this in let me color all the
ones that meet our constraints this is
getting a tail on the third one a tail
on the second one and a heads on the
first so that's at least two tails
here we have tails heads heads that
doesn't meet it
tails heads tails that does
so let's color this one in
and then tails tails well if you've got
a tail on the first and the second then
either of these are going to meet the
constraints because you already got two
tails so that one meets it that you got
tails tails heads and tails tails tails
both of them
so
let's go back to the question what is
the probability that you'll get at least
two tails well how many equally likely
outcomes are there we're assuming this
is a fair coin we see that there are
one two three four five six seven eight
equally likely outcomes and how many of
these outcomes met are constraints
one two three four
four
out of the eight
four eighths which could also be viewed
is equivalent to
one half the probability that i'll get
at least two tails is one half